- On this episode, I invite
Tucker Max the jam with me.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
this is The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 207 of
The #AskGaryVee Show.
I'm excited.
We've got a guest.
I'll let this wonderful
man introduce himself.
I know a lot of
you know who he is.
It's post-Memorial Day but
first and foremost and more
importantly than anything else,
I want to give a huge shoutout
to my baby daughter,
Misha, happy seventh birthday.
I will be running out of here in
a second to go see you at school
do the cupcake thing.
Very excited, I love
you with all my heart.
Speaking about love, India.
- [India] Hi.
- It's good to see you.
- Good to see you.
- How you been?
- Good.
- You've been
away forever I feel.
I feel like I haven't
seen you in years.
Did you go to the
west coast or something?
- No, I was in DC for
one night on Thursday.
- Oh, that was cool.
You have a good time?
- Yeah.
I went to see a movie
at the White House.
- Was it fun?
- It was awesome.
- Did you see the President?
- No, he was out of town.
He let me know
though before time.
- He let you know?
- Yeah.
- For one night?
You got the questions?
- I got the questions.
- Ready for the show?
- I'm ready for the show.
- Alright, let's go to
our guest, my friend.
Why don't you tell the Vayner
Nation, actually I will eat this
salad while you do this part,
who you are and
what you're up to.
- Alright, so my
name is Tucker Max.
I wrote a book called "I Hope
They Serve Beer in Hell" which
spent like half a decade on the
bestseller list and there is a
movie made about it and whatever
and now I have a company called
Book in a Box.
- And what is Book in the Box?
- We turn ideas in to books.
If you have an idea for a book
and you don't want to sit at a
computer for a year typing it
out we have a process where we
interview you, we position the
idea, structure it and create an
outline, get everything--
- Is the interview process
almost like a version of
ghostwriting which then
allows the book to be created?
- No so ghostwriting is like
if you're hiring a ghostwriter,
you're hiring someone to write
their version of your ideas in
your book and you're paying them
so you can put your name on it.
- Yes.
- With us our process doesn't
work if you don't know exactly
what you're talking about
because it's all your
own content.
We're adding nothing to it.
It's almost like an algorithm
but a structured process where
great writers and editors are
guiding you through it asking
questions so it
feels like magic to you.
All you're doing is talking
about what you already know.
- You know what's
weird about this?
This is actually
how I do my books.
- It's how you do your books.
- Yeah.
I basically just talk and get
interviewed by Steph and to me
and then I don't know in your
world this works and then I
basically all the editing that I
do is always basically my dream
scenario is that, A, she
helps me structure for sure.
One continuous run, I'd have
one long run-on sentence.
That'd be my book.
And two, grammar,
and then any word
scares the, I'm always petrified
do I even say that?
Would I say that word?
It's really just the
transcription of the
conversation.
- We don't do transcription it's
more we interview because spoken
word is different than written.
- 100%.
- So once we've got it
structured in the interview the
job of the editor is to
interview you, get everything
out your head and then once
it is transcribed to translate
that into written.
- And how did this happen?
Was this a scenario where, it's
funny, this is the first time
we're meeting, right?
- Yeah.
Which is crazy 'cause we have
seriously hundreds of
friends in common.
- Friends in common, yeah.
What I know from afar is I
assume what happened was
you had this... Actually,
you know what let's take
it there for a second.
This book was a smash hit.
- My first one? Yeah.
- Right.
You definitely didn't think
that's what's gonna happen.
- Of course not.
- How did you even get to the
point of writing that first one?
Why did you write a book?
- It's funny. I started I went to
law school my friends and I went
to different cities to work.
- Your law school friends?
- Yeah, right.
All law school friends.
I got fired--
- Where'd you grow up?
- Kentucky.
- Love it.
- Total BFE Kentucky.
Nowhere Kentucky.
- Love it.
- You love it because
you didn't grow up there.
It's a terrible place.
There's a reason
everyone leaves.
- Got it. Middle of
nowhere Kentucky.
And then where
did you go to school?
- University of Chicago for
undergrad and then
Duke for law school.
- Impressive.
Nowhere Kentucky
taught you something.
- School is easy once you
learn how to hack the system.
- I nevered
figure that part out.
Okay and so you go and do that
and so you think you're going to
be a lawyer?
- Yeah.
- That's like what's up.
- Mhmmm.
And then I got fired--
- From nowhere Kentucky that
was like holy shit you made it.
- Yeah, sort of.
I came from a family, they
weren't really rich but pretty
well known--
- In the area?
- Yeah.
My grandfather was a doctor, my
mom was one of the first women,
sorry my grandmother was one of
the first women to ever graduate
from the University of
Kentucky so I came from
a family of achievers.
My great great great grandfather
was a US Senator,
maybe four greats. Way far back.
- So you needed this
book to get into the game?
- Exactly.
- So you go to law school you
get some buddies, you guys are
going different
places where did you go?
What city?
- I moved to Silicon
Valley to Mountain View.
I was working for a firm
called Fenwick and West.
- I know them.
- Right. Of course.
- I've used them
for some of my deals.
- There you go.
Well, they fired me.
- Amazing.
- And I deserved it though.
They weren't dicks.
I deserved to be fired.
- Because?
- The reason I thought I got
fired was I got super drunk at
this big law firm event.
- Yeah.
- There's like an auction and I
grabbed the mic and I basically
yelled at the other people who
are bidding on me for this thing
and it was really funny
but it was kind of
mildly inappropriate but not.
I didn't quite cross the line.
I thought I got fired--
- This was to win
a date with you?
- No, it was like the hiring
partner was driving people
around for a night.
You know, it was a
charity auction.
It was some nonsense thing.
- Yep.
- And I was blind drunk, like
double fisting bottles of wine.
I was a 25-year-old moron.
- You were drinking wine?
- Oh, yeah dude.
- I love that.
- It was at Silverado.
It was at the
resort, yeah, in Napa.
I don't know what I
was drinking though.
I was hammered and I thought
that's why got fired but the
real reason is actually because
the senior female partner in the
firm propositioned me and I
did the worst possible thing I
turned her down and then I told
everybody. If I had slept with
her I would have been
basically bulletproof.
- And this is what happened?
- And if I had shut up,
I'd've been fine. Right?
- Okay.
- I ended up getting fired,
it was both things combined.
I was a reckless
unguided missile.
I had no business
working in a law firm.
They were totally right to
fire me but the real instigating
factor was that.
- What happens next?
Your fired, the next day.
- Then I go work for my dad, it
was kind of like a whole mess.
I basically got blackballed from
the legal profession 'cause
I wrote my friends
an email about it.
About the events,
the drinking right?
- Yes.
- That was like Saturday.
I ended up getting
fired Wednesday.
So on Monday I wrote this really
funny email, sent it to my
friends, I get fired and of
course my friends are dicks so
they forward this
email to everybody.
- What year is this?
- This is 2000, 2001.
- Back when people
forwarded to their entire list.
- This is before Myspace
or anything like that.
- The original
social media, email.
- Exactly it was email forwards.
- Uh-huh.
- So I get blackballed from
the legal profession because
everyone gets this email
of me telling this story.
- Yep.
Let me ask you a real straight
up question that I'm curious if
it's ever been asked,
how much
subconsciously or consciously?
- A lot. I know exactly what
you're going to ask.
- Do people ask that?
- No.
- Yeah, right, nobody's,
everyone's scared to
ask you the right question.
I'm not scared and
I want to bring value.
I'm listening to this
I'm like this guy--
- You're right.
You're right.
- Do you actually know
that you had this in you?
Did you think you're a comedian?
Did you think your
culture hacker?
What do you think was brewing?
You understood
something was brewing?
- Yeah.
- There's no way that you're
here and have that,
you see where I'm going?
- So we were talking
about this actually.
She went to law school too and
I think being a lawyer is a
terrible job for the most
part for most people.
And I'm pretty high-energy,
I'm pretty creative,
I'm pretty entrepreneurial,
I like to do things different
and that's the opposite
of what you want to be.
If you're a lawyer you're just
following rules and you're
somebody else's paper monkey.
- Of course.
- I think I realized that but
quite honestly, dude, I don't
think I had the courage to
do anything about it or the
emotional maturity to
even recognize that.
That's where the
unconscious stuff comes in.
I'm going to act out and force
them to do something that
I don't have the courage to
do myself especially at 25.
No way.
- What happens next?
- I went to work my dad.
He owns a restaurant
company in south Florida.
So I actually know
a lot about wine,
my other side of family
is restaurants.
- That's cool.
- Then he ends up firing me six
months later, my own dad fires
me from the family business.
- My dad fired my sister.
Actually here's an unknown
fact, my dad fired me once.
I was fired by Sasha.
That is a real thing.
I who worked every minute of my
god damn life once asked in my
senior year to leave at 7 PM,
which was considered early,
a 10 hour day, to go to a
graduation party and
my dad said I wasn't
committed to the business--
- You own graduation?
- My own high school graduation.
You don't understand, I worked
every day of high school,
every weekend,
every summer vacation.
This weekend I spent time with
my family, we got a place and
I'm like I finally understand
why people summer so much 'cause
I never had one
since seventh grade.
And my dad fired me
so I understand being
fired by your dad.
And by the way I won that battle
and dad you know it because
I then was pumped I had two days
free to myself in the summer.
I was like wait a minute
hung out with my friends,
played wiffleball, I went to
a baseball card show.
I was not asking to come
back and then my dad had to say
what'd he say?
He walked in my room
he's like,
"I'll see you at seven
the morning."
I'm like alright.
- I think that is a difference
between you and me.
I did get fired
for that stuff, man.
I got fired because
I was a jackass.
I got fired for
totally legit reasons.
The long, long story is
basically that my dad had a
bunch of clowns working for
him and I was 25 and stupid
and didn't understand
anything about the world.
I thought my dad has a great
business, I know I can expand
this and I went in and I told
the clowns working for him that
they weren't good enough to work
there and I was going to get
them fired and I was
going to build this business.
- Yeah.
- This is my social
intelligence at the time.
And of course these people all
know office politics and my dad
much better than I do.
- Yeah.
- But I still think
it doesn't matter.
I'm right and my name's on the
door obviously my dad is going
to pick me. So then I also give
me all the ammunition in the
world by doing things like
I'll meet some girl at
the restaurant--
- Real quick because of this is
the important theme for them,
trying to bring them value,
again you think subconsciously?
- Yes. Well here's
what happens--
- Let me ask you the question
that's burning inside of me?
Did you know that you had this
kind of personality that you,
did you literally think did
you understand the internet well
enough at that point?
But did you think that you
were going to become
famous or a personality?
- The God honest answer is--
- Like really?
- I really honestly mostly
lucked in to a lot of stuff.
I lucked into a lot
of opportunities.
I picked up those opportunities
and busted my ass
once I had them.
- Did you think that you
had a likable personality
to dudes and bros?
- No, because I was no
different than my nine friends.
The guys I went to law school,
in the terms of intelligence or
social ability or funny I was
dead in the middle at best.
- Right. Right.
- I had a lot of friends
who were funnier than me.
I'm just dude who wrote it
all down and the reason I wrote
down, I get fired--
- Is that what the book was?
They were stories?
- The first like eight stories
in the book are the emails
I sent my friends.
They're emails.
- Actually real quick I know we
have questions 'cause this is
being more of an interview than
The #AskGaryVee Show but
I'm enjoying it plus this is
like eight years of
pent up friendship.
- Exactly.
- I just want to get
some context,
how did the book deal happen?
- I actually I tried to
get published.
So I wrote these emails
to my friends about all the
stories, the dumb things that
I did that got me fired like
having a girl I hooked up with
some girl in the bathroom
when I was on shift and
all these sort of things.
So I gave them all the
ammunition to talk bad
about me to my dad.
He fires me and I write
emails about all the dumb
things I'm doing, drinking
hooking up with these
girls in south Florida
and those emails
my friends are like
"This is the funniest stuff
I've ever read."
You're not that funny in
person but you're funny emails.
- Were you getting an amazing
high from the feedback of your
friends reaction so much?
Making it self-populating.
- It wasn't about writing,
it was about making
my friends laugh.
- Mhmmm.
- It never occurred to me that
anyone would think these emails
were funny outside
of my nine friends.
- Right.
- After I get fired from both
jobs, one of my friends was like
look man, you're not good at
anything else but you're real
good at writing these emails,
this is what you should do.
It never occurred to me be a
writer at that point so I sent
my emails every agent, every
publisher this is '01, late '01.
Maybe early '02,
everyone I could find
100%, without
exception, rejection.
Most people ignored it and the
people that responded were--
- Rude.
- rude.
- Most of them are
like "dick face."
- Most of it was
just form rejection.
There were for three or four
personalized you're the worst
writer I've ever seen.
You need to go die.
- I genuinely hate you.
Dear Tucker, I hate you.
- Right. I got into writing to
keep people like you out of it.
- HarperCollins.
- Seriously, for real.
- So who published you?
- So after that I ended up
getting this dude
Jeremie Ruby-Strauss who
worked at Kensington which was,
still is kind of
a small publisher.
He found my blog, loved it.
Thought it was the
funniest thing he ever read.
- Wait a minute,
there's a little piece there.
You started putting these
articles you know
what I'm trying.
- I got rejected from--
- This is a business show,
what I'm more fascinated by
you clearly knew what was
happening with the
current state of the internet
during that period of time.
You're doing emails that you
know are getting forwarded.
You just went into a blog.
If we're talking '01, '02
what are you blogging on?
Blogger? Typepad?
- GeoCities!
GeoCities!
- This is the part I think
it is most interesting to me.
- TypePad! I wish.
- Right. To that point to me
always thinking about
how to extract value such
a big portion knows who are,
read that book,
things of that nature
but so many don't.
- Right.
- To me again, here's another
person that executed in a
platform that was underrated
attention and used it to expand.
- The thing is I get rejected
by all the gatekeepers, right?
This is still '01, '02.
I get rejected by all of them.
- You go directly
to the consumer.
- I didn't know what else to do.
The internet, GeoCities was
starting to blow up so I was
like I'll just put my stories
out for free and everyone
literally laughed at me
because how could you do that.
You have to charge for writing.
And I'm like I have
nowhere else to publish this.
- Distribution.
- And then it blew up it
took about 4 to 6 months.
- What was it called?
- It was called TuckerMax.com.
- Even better.
That's what I'd name it.
- This girl ended up suing
because I wrote about her.
It was all true.
- Did you say her name?
- Oh yeah.
It was all 100% true and it
was a big First Amendment case.
She got this temporary
restraining order issued
prior restraint, long, long story.
But blew my site up and
then after that it got all this
traffic and I won the case
'cause I was telling the truth
and I was right.
Then publishers all came back to
me and the guy I ended up going
with was the guy who I had
the best relationship, right.
- Yep.
- Book didn't
come out until '06.
That was '02, '03.
- Why'd it take so long?
You had more shenanigans.
- It was a lot of bullshit.
Mainstream publishing
all that stuff.
- Yeah.
- But the cool thing is, I bit
my email list the whole time.
Not even trying.
I didn't really understand it.
I just had the email list
because it's the
easiest way to reach people.
- And it's how you started.
- By the time the book came out
I had a 50, 100,000 people so
I sold 6,000 copies
the first week.
Literally zero reviews, no one
talked about this book anywhere.
I hit the New York Times
bestseller list out of nowhere.
- Right.
- And I was that first, my book
was the very first one to go
blog to bestseller.
- Love it.
- Very first.
- Did you get a lot
of coverage for that?
- Not really.
That was still back when
media was like
"Who are these
blog people?
"These Internet
people, they don't matter.
"They don't exist."
- This is when?
- '06, January 2006.
- That's right when Wine Library
TV started. That's awesome.
I remember your wine
show was blowing up
about the same time mine was.
You were just all
these different--
- Genre.
- All these people
different kind of
finding their ways
in to things,
kind of by accident.
Book kind of took off and
then went down and
then built by
word-of-mouth after that.
People credit me for all I've
done all these marketing things,
oh that's so smart.
I honestly don't think
any of that stuff mattered.
I think the fact that I wrote a
great book that a lot of people
love and told
their friends about.
- And you referenced
earlier first book,
you've written more than one?
- Four.
- Four in that genre.
Like the New York Times called
it "fratire" which makes no
sense because I wasn't in
a fraternity but whatever.
And then now, I've
retired from that because--
- You had your run.
- You can't act like
your 20s in your 40s.
- That's right.
All right, India.
That was fun.
- [India] Yeah, that was fun.
The first one from Taylor.
- India's going to ask questions
and we're going to answer them.
- Shoot. Let's do it.
- [Voiceover] Taylor asks, "What
has been the biggest key to your
"creative process and
the ability to tell stories
"that connect people?"
- That is a great question.
The way I always frame it, and
I think it started this way by
accident and I've just stayed
this way, is I started writing
because I was trying to
make nine people laugh.
You know the saying if you want
to change the world, you got to
start with one person either
yourself or one person first.
I think the same thing
is true for storytelling.
If you can't make a small people
laugh or react in whatever way
you looking to get--
- You're dead.
- you can't get a get
big group to do it. Right?
Every time I write I always
think consciously in my head
who is my audience,
why do they care?
- Super interesting.
You guys have heard
Sally Arkansas,
his world would be
like Rick Polo.
I imagine these people that
I think that there's way
more than nine of them.
Your nine buddies represent
22% of dudes in America.
- Exactly.
- And that's why it's a big
audience and that's
what I think about here.
Even the way I interviewed in
the first 10, 15 minutes here.
I'm like okay, I know
who's watching.
Boy, girl, black, white, green,
alien. They're entrepreneurial,
they care about things as I
was listening and getting more
context on what I
generally know.
This guy won and
did well in books.
I'm like wait a minute, this guy
knew, this guy knew with email
forwarding and
blogging very early.
Again, always trying to drill
home for them that white space.
So that's what I do.
I reverse engineer what
is the biggest value?
Wine Library TV worked because
I spent 10 years in a wine shop
and watched people come in and
people that were like Duke law
lawyers who are like
- Super intelligent about wine.
- Alpha males walking in the
store and I need a bottle,
god wine world is so
douchey, so suppressive.
In the same way I think
about entrepreneurship, right?
Now I just want to empower
people to be like who gives a
shit when people, just do it.
Reverse engineer
is very similar.
Go ahead.
- [Voiceover] Jonathan wants
to know, "Last time I heard the
"name Tucker Max I finished 'I
Hope They Serve Beer in Hell'.
"Lots has changed.
Would you do it all again?"
- Of course.
- It's what got you here, right?
- I would try and do a
lot of things differently.
- Like what?
What's the most, in a no
bullshit way because
I'm enjoying this.
Because I think you can--
- There is no other way
to be in no bullshit.
- Knowing again back why you
were happy, I want to go to a
place where I know you've been
on so many different things.
In a very fucking real way,
what's the one core thing you
think you would do different?
- I would realize a lot
earlier that it's not about me.
Even though, I'm really
good about that my art.
My stories, even though they are
about me, if you read all four
of my books you actually don't
know very much about at all.
You know a lot about things that
happened to me and
you've laughed a lot and
you've really enjoyed it.
But I don't burden the reader
with nonsense about me because
people reading my books
want to be entertained.
They're not trying to learn
deep about my emotions,
whatever, right?
But the what may I make
business decisions,
early in my career I was
arrogant and stupid and
I made most
of my decisions--
- Because you thought
you have the leverage?
- There was a movie
made about my first book.
That movie should have done
$100 million or more at the
box office and it did
like $2 million.
- Because?
- Because of my
arrogance and my hubris.
- You wanted to impose
certain things that you had
creative control over?
- Yeah, man.
It really was.
Writing is a very singular art.
I don't need anyone
else's help to crush a book.
To make a movie, it's a
whole group of people.
And even the smallest
movie ever is still 50 on it.
- And you went into that place
of like look, "I love you"--
- This is about me holding tight
and because of that I picked the
wrong director, I picked
most of the wrong production.
- You picked yes-people?
- No, if I picked yes-people it
might have been just my vision
which would have been
better than what it was.
- 'Cause it became
a Frankenstein.
- Yeah.
- It was half pregnant.
- Yeah. Exactly.
And I picked a lot of people who
told me what I wanted to hear
early on but had
their own agendas.
- Sure.
- I was blind to it and I was so
caught up in myself and my own
ego that I screwed up a really
massive opportunity for myself.
- Sure. It was a game changer.
If that goes for a hundo,
different things.
You know it's funny people
always ask me my biggest mistake
and I always try to come up with
something because I don't like
to think about my mistakes.
I actually disrespect
my mistakes,--
- Right.
- it's a very interesting thing.
I recognize them but I
give them no fucking energy.
- Right.
- Really, I'm like cool
mistake you go over there.
No question my biggest mistakes
have been the things that have
passed on and haven't done.
- Yeah.
- It was interesting to think
about and that happened but
I could have been a
judge on "Top Chef".
I could've do all these
other business shows.
There's a lot of things I always
that I always think about the
things I that I haven't done.
Investing, right?
I've done well but passing on
Uber twice was the clear one.
- I did too.
- Everybody did.
- I know.
- Everybody had an at-bat.
Alright, let's go.
- [Voiceover] Daniela asks,
"I'm an immigrant with
"an entrepreneurial dream.
"All my parents care about
is college which I hate.
"Any advice?"
- That's tough.
- Did you get pressured
to be a good student?
- No. I came from one of
those families where
it's just expected.
- Right.
It was binary, right?
- I came from one of those--
There wasn't even
a conversation.
- No, it just wasn't
even a conversation.
I came from one of those weird
families where high expectations
were always there but my parents
were not very good at being
parents so I was basically
ignored so I kinda
had to raise myself.
But unconsciously--
- You have siblings?
- No. Only child.
- Only child.
- I think unconsciously I
understood at a very young age
that the adults were
never going help me.
No one was coming to help me and
so I had to learn the system as
it's presented to
you is bullshit.
The only gift they gave me of
being terrible parents is that
I was never fooled by the
lies that the system tells you.
Like school.
I learned how to
hack the system.
- You feel like early on you
made a decision that you weren't
getting value from your parents
and thus every grown up during
your youth you looked in
the cynical point of view?
- Not just the grown ups but the
actual systems that the grown
ups are operating
and represented.
Whether it's work or whether
it's corporations or school.
It's not that everything is
invalid, it's just that the face
that they present is
never the reality.
- It's so interesting, I on the
other hand had amazing parents
but came to that same
realization at a very young age.
- Yeah.
- It's so interesting different
paths to get that place.
It's really dictated my life
where I was like,
"Oh my god, I'm not this.
"I've got another," geez I
was in fourth grade for sure.
I'm like, "Crap, I've got
another nine years of
eating this shit."
- You got out early, I'm like,
"How do I break this system?"
"How do I hack it and
make it work for me?"
- Yeah, you decided
to win within it.
I decided to literally go on
vacation because I realized
subconsciously I was never
going to be on vacation again.
- If we're talking
about unconscious.
I think I realized
I had no other support,
you had great parents.
I have this other
world I can go into.
- You're like, "I need this."
I respect that.
- I need to win at this system
so that I have 'cause
I don't have anyone else.
- What's the person's name?
- [India] Daniela.
- Daniela, I'm going to give
you very difficult advice.
I really do you need to have
the most honest and truthful
conversation you've ever had
with your parents and then
react to their reaction.
I don't know if you've ever
gone there all the way
where this is really ruining me.
Not like "Hey mom and
dad, I don't like school."
It's like, "I'm suffocating and
truly believe my life will not
be as good as it could be
if I go down this path."
Watching your parents' reaction
to those words verbatim
will give you a really
good indication.
Because then you get to
understand are your parents
wired to really value you and
where you are and
what's in your best interest
from your point of view
or do they really care
about their point of view and
what their child's success
means to them.
I've become very fascinated.
You might have
better insight on this.
I grew up in a way where I
didn't know the fancy world so
bumper stickers of colleges on
cars and parents telling kids to
take on college debt
at better schools.
Wait a minute, that's that their
interest 'cause they get to tell
their friends University
of Chicago is real fancy.
I'd be super pumped if
Misha and Xander went there.
I'm like holy crap
that's interesting.
- I think that's fantastic advice.
Let me just add one
sort of way to frame this.
So when you go talk to your
parents, I think the way to
frame it is not here's my
argument 'cause you're never
going to convince someone with
a compelling argument
or very rarely.
What you want to do is
start by asking them questions.
Do you care about me?
How much do you care?
What do you really care about?
What matters the most to you?
And what they're gonna say is,
"We care about you being happy.
"We care about you
finding yourself."
Whatever, right?
Get them to commit to that and
then say alright if you really
do care about me and you really
do it doesn't matter to you that
I am this happy, I'm going to
tell you I don't want to go to
school because it makes a very,
or college, it makes me very
unhappy and trying these other
things for a year or two is
going to make much happier.
Will you support me
as I do something?
And you can even
frame it as temporary.
Give me a year or two, support
me and if it doesn't work I'm
happy to go back to college.
- And support me
mentally, right?
The financial part--
- That's totally what I mean.
- I know that.
- Emotional.
I want to frame
that up for people.
And I would say the other thing
like look, there's casualties of
war and your parents are not
going to be around for your
casualties of what
they think is in your
better interest than versus you.
The gift that I was given that
I really wish I could stick into
every god damn person is the
audacity and confidence at a
very young age to just
say this is the deal.
That independence is incredible.
And that's a hard
for a lot of people.
If you're asking me on this
show, to me actions speak louder
than words if you publicly
tweeted this and asked me and
wanted me to answer your just
looking for somebody to
push you over the finish line.
Many of you are watching this
and think it would but never
tweet it publicly in fear
that your parents would see it.
You're clearly this close and
you need somebody to nudge you.
I'm willing to nudge you.
I really do think there are real
moments in time to say go fuck
yourself mom and dad.
And it's real and
it's real not from a bad,
cool like bro-ing out,
from a this is it.
This is a crossroads and
a lot of people give
forced into doing it.
There are kids with massive debt
because they wanted to appease
their parents and they lose.
They lose because they kick
their 20s and don't take the
risk reward things they should
be doing to just pay down the
debt and they wake up at 34 and
a just finally are at even from
something that
they decided at 17.
- Because their
parents pressured them.
- 100%.
- Yeah.
- Now that I've gotten older and
I'm spending time with parents,
in their parents
vested interest of vanity.
- Yes.
- The worst.
Let's do one more.
Speaking of parents, I gotta
run to Misha's school.
- Hey Gary, I'm
Steven from Columbia.
I am 10 years old.
My question is if I want to make
videos about cars, motorcycles
because I love it or my life in
general, I mean vlogs because
I love it too, what should I do?
Because you say that you work
so hard until 30 and
you say that people will
respect you for your actions.
I dream of being a
successful entrepreneur and
I want respect too.
But hold out for results?
Or I should work in silence?
I mean, no camera?
No social media?
What should I do, Gary please?
I want to go all-in.
I love you man and anybody
in this planet like you.
Sorry for my English.
- English is amazing.
Much better to my Spanish.
- Bye.
- He even edited
with the subtitles.
- Amazing.
What's his name?
Steven?
- [India] Steven.
Steven, I'll jump in real quick
and Tucker please
add anything you can to this.
I want to give you a definition.
I said that I built a business
until I was 30, 32 and then
I talked about business stuff
instead of being a 20-year-old
giving business advice.
You're a content producer.
You're talking
about your opinions.
That's different.
If you were giving advice as
a 10-year-old, 20-year-old,
30-year-old about building
a business or building a
motorcycle business or things
of that nature, that's very
different than you
pontificating, giving your two
cents, adding to culture, social
commentating so what I want to
give you definition is my whole
wait 'til you're 30 to talk to
the world, if you're going to
give advice I do think it should
be predicated on something
advice giving your two cents
we're all entitled
to our opinions.
Social commentating,
we're all entitled to that.
Making videos and commentating,
I think the journey of your life
and your thoughts and
those things is super fine.
You clearly, I mean,
I would push very hard.
What I just saw gave me
a nice little tingle.
Keep pounding, produce content,
use all the platforms,
use your youth
and native ability
on this world that
we now live in
musically, Snapchat,
produce for all mediums.
Get it out there.
Tucker.
- Yeah.
It seems to me like he has
a lot of charisma, right?
- I agree.
- He totally can be
a content producer.
So then ask yourself
what we talked about,
the very first question.
What audience do you
want to talk to and
what do they care about?
And there's a lot of young guys,
I'd bet in Columbia, who care
about cars and motorcycles and
that stuff, if you become the
guy who speaks to all them that
puts you in a great to start a
lot of different businesses.
- Or I can tell,
that's exactly right.
Or I can tell you another thing,
there's a lot of people that are
actually just curious
about youth life and
culture in Columbia is.
I was watching that
looking in the background.
Can I learn something what the
kids, I actually just think your
life is actually interesting to
so many people and nobody,
if you're not in Columbia,
you can't produce content around
Columbia so use your
advantages that so many
people think
are disadvantages.
- Right, exactly.
- My man.
- Super nice, man.
- You get a parting shot here
anything you want to ramble on
and then a question of the day.
This is a great
focus group opportunity.
So insight that you
may be looking for.
There's a ton of aspiring--
- You want me
to ask a question?
- Yeah. Every guest gets to ask
the question of the day.
There's a ton of aspiring,
I mean hundreds of people have
emailed me around writing a
book and things of that nature.
I know you guys
are jamming on that.
- Yeah.
- Any question about that or any
insight that you're looking for.
- I was looking on Twitter
right before you came in.
- Yeah.
- A bunch of people asked
questions about writing books?
We actually wrote a book that
details our entire process.
To hire us is really expensive.
- Yep.
- It's like 20 grand
for Book in a Box.
But we wrote a book that
tells exactly what we do.
- Let's definitely
link that up, Staphon.
- So just go to
bookinabox.com/Gary
your fans can go there and
they get a free copy
of the book if they want it.
And literally step-by-step
process to use our method to
write their own book.
It takes more time than if you
hire us but it's the exact same
templates, everything
start to end.
- Super smart. Data
in exchange for good content.
That's great.
- bookinabox.com/Gary
- Good man. Thanks for that.
- 'Course.
- And now question.
You get to ask any question.
Any question.
Could be silly, we'll
sit here for 45 minutes.
- You got a smart
audience who's good at media.
So anyone who's
interested go look at our site,
bookinabox.com, what do you
think they we're doing wrong in
terms of messaging or marketing.
- Free analyzation.
- Our audiences are people who
have great ideas for books, who
can monetize those ideas like
coaches, consultants, CEOs,
entrepreneurs, people
who've had success.
What are we doing right and
wrong to talk to those people?
Any ideas you have please send
to me, Tucker@bookinabox.com,
I'd would love to hear them.
- Tucker, thanks for being on.
- Thank you.
- You you keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
What's up guys?
Hope you enjoyed the show.
Please do I get to
link it up anywhere?
Is it in here or
is it down below?
Is it in print or in my video?
- [Staphon] It'll be down
to your left.
- It's here down to my left.
Right here, there's a button
for them to subscribe
to my YouTube video?
Yeah it's that
little buggy thing.
That's right guys, click this.
That's right, use that.